hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to a
special video edition of ask Evan today
I'm going to answer a question for one
of my readers Angela who asked me how I
grew my business without spending any
money on advertising
Angela's question comes from our
Facebook page I recently posted a list
here of my favorite tools and these are
tools that I use to run my business and
she left a comment saying under the
growing your business portion I have to
wonder with regard to marketing the
brand is that it certainly I found you
via a link from another website with the
right hook to reel me in I found an
attractive and useful website to keep me
hooked I opted for the email newsletter
because I wanted more and liked on
Facebook for real-time feeling
reinforced when the positive inspiring
stories it doesn't seem to me at all
like you've wasted thousands on any
advertising am i correct my employer put
me in charge of building our web
presence and we don't have a big budget
nor do I have much time for this as I
have other responsibilities but your
formula here seems simple and it works
please advise if I've missed something
here your beacon I truly value be doing
well first of all Angela thank you for
for the kind words
I replied below Angela my advertising
budget is zero dollars everything has
been done through SEO social media and
the media and by the media I mean
offline traditional media and I thought
I'd create this quick video to expand on
that a little bit more and show you
exactly how I built my business without
having to spend any money on advertising
so here we go
the first thing I recommend is to make
smart use of seo seo is great because it
drives targeted traffic to your website
and it's people who are looking to solve
a problem right they've searched in a
keyword because they have a problem and
hopefully you can help solve it but SEO
starts with having really good content
so you have to think about the content
that you're gonna have on your site that
start driving some of that traffic when
I first started my site I was writing
out the content and I really started
around doing these famous entrepreneur
profiles so here's one example to neva
Roddick who's the founder of the body
shop and I would start writing some of
this content because I found it
inspiring and then one of the reasons
that my business was able to grow is I
delegated some of those responsibilities
so I realized I could only do so much in
terms of content creation so I ended up
hiring somebody to help me create these
famous entrepreneur profiles and now we
have the largest collection of famous
entrepreneur profiles online and you can
see some of the people who we've
profiled here on the side and then we
open it up to allowing other experts who
able to brighten between be content to
the site and we created an article
director here where there's all these
different categories and people can
contribute content you know if your
business coach you can add articles to
our website that deal with business
coaching show off your expertise each
one will get manually reviewed by an
editor on our team and then we'll go
live and help to promote the business so
you have to try to find ways to give
incentives to people to want to
contribute content to the site so it's
not just you doing everything this works
especially well if your time crunched
and you have other responsibilities like
like you mentioned so you want to make
sure you can get other people involved
and you want to try to find an incentive
to do so you don't have to go and create
a huge content site like mine but you
want to think about how you can add
regular content to your website
a quick example that I can show you is
through my blog and on the blog you'll
see that I've created a whole bunch of
content myself and I'll write on a
regular basis still talking about famous
entrepreneurs so the five gutsiest
entrepreneurs of all time but then I'll
also get some help and we'll do
infographics so these are pictures
describing articles I will do lists of
top 50 blogs on a certain category and
this I have outsourced to people on my
team and will also do interviews so here
we have an interview with Stan Procop
another interview he down here with Brad
Swift who are both experts and authors
on my website and that's a great way to
get content onto your website without
you having to do a lot of work
so you're basically asking questions and
hopefully it's content that'd be
relevant to your readers and it's a
great way to generate that content and
start driving traffic to your website so
you want to start thinking about the
types of content that you can add to
your site on a regular basis and what
you can do yourself what you might be
able to do with other people on your
team and then also potentially people
outside your team how they might be able
to contribute content to your website
so SEO helped drive a lot of traffic to
my website we've had millions of
entrepreneurs check it out over the
years but now most of my time is spent
naturally on the social media side and I
really enjoyed it's a way to connect
with with entrepreneurs on a more
personal level and try to build
relationships with some of the people
who are checking out your site that can
be a little challenging through just a
SEO presence so one of the first things
you want to do after you set up your
accounts I spend most of my time on
Twitter Facebook and YouTube and you
want to make it really easy for people
to be able to find you and follow you on
different accounts so at the top of all
of my pages you'll see I have a banner
that looks like this it has my blog my
tweets my facebook my youtube videos and
lists of my tools so you can easily find
me depending on if you're more of a
Twitter person or Facebook or YouTube so
you want to make that really obvious for
people I find it's really helpful if you
keep - a posting schedule so come up
with ideas of what you're going to be
able to talk about I tend to focus on
the business side of things I'm not
posting about my dog or what I'm eating
for breakfast but high-value things that
I think entrepreneurs would be
interesting and find inspirational and
you can see a mix of things that I post
so if I click on my Twitter account
you'll see that I'm a thank them I may
do some personal responses to people who
have enjoyed my tweets I'll post links
to things that I enjoy some videos that
I'm working on I'll post quotes from
famous entrepreneurs that I think are
inspiring and I'll usually post one to
three times a day so it's not overload
for people and people end up subscribing
and retweeting and it's a great way to
start building connections with people
who are talking about you and you want
to encourage those people because they
are out there telling all their friends
about you so you want to recognize them
and give them the opportunity to tell
even more people
on my facebook channel I'll do similar
things Facebook is really good for
pictures so one of the things I've done
is I take pictures of people who I'm
meeting with and I'll put them in here
and I'll profile them and put a link
back to their site I'll also show things
such as when I'm reading just refresh
that and you can also ask questions of
the week so I'll ask a question every
week and get a lot of replies and it's a
really great way again to connect with
your community of followers and be able
to follow up with them on an individual
basis so you want to empower your
champions you may not find out about
these people normally through your SEO
that's not loading but something may be
happening with Facebook at the moment
but I'm newer on Facebook and I really
like it as an opportunity to be able to
connect with with readers finally
YouTube is where I spend a lot of time
as well and I'll try to create videos on
an ongoing basis so here's my YouTube
channel and you can see some of the
videos that that we've launched if I
click on see y'all it'll show all of
them and it'll show that you know they
get some good views and they get some
good comments and it's again a great way
I try to reply to every comment that
that gets put up on my video and if
people give a thumbs up and leave
comments on it again you know hopefully
they're telling their friends and
they're coming back to the site and
you're trying to encourage them to be a
little more sticky with the website than
just coming we didn't want use of
content and taking off another great way
to encourage this is through a
newsletter and that's how a lot of
people end up sticking on my website so
I've got over here an option on all of
our pages to sign up to join my
newsletter and here I'll send them
weekly tips and advice nothing really
selling product but more offering value
add information I think is inspiring and
helpful and that's a great way to get
people to come back to your site so
somebody who lands on your website they
may
something but then you know they go off
somewhere else you may not ever get them
back again so if you have a newsletter
and a great way to get them to sign up
to join the newsletter then you have a
way to stay in touch with them offer
them deals give them high value
information but the point here of the
the newsletter and social media is we
start building our relationship with
people you become known as the expert
for whatever category you're in and a
trusted resource and whenever somebody
needs help they're going to come back to
you to hopefully buy your service or
sign up for your products or whatever it
is that eventually you're able to make
money from the last point I want to talk
about is the use of offline media and
offline media is still very powerful we
may think in the online world because
we're online entrepreneurs but you still
want to be able to hopefully use some
offline media to generate some awareness
about your business and showcase
yourself as an expert so I love doing
offline media if you check out my about
page I've created a page that shows some
of the media coverage that I've done
been fortunate to get a number of pretty
high profile media coverage and you want
to showcase that you're an expert so
whatever industry you're in you better
be good at it if you're going to become
an entrepreneur and be successful so why
not expose your expertise to the media
and be able to comment on stories as I
come out what I've done is highlighted
some of the media that I've been
involved with and then show at the
bottom if people want to interview you
mean here's email address to be able to
connect with me I what I did when I
first was getting started was I made a
list of all the different media outlets
that I could think of and started to go
through one by one and find Entrepreneur
related
News reporters who have at those media
outlets and I would draft a new press
release every two weeks and send it out
and every time I did that I would always
get some kind of reply from somebody and
the key here is when you do a press
release you don't want to just focus on
you right you're not focusing on a
product or service you're launching
because people don't care about that you
want to pitch a story and then you want
to showcase your expertise in answering
questions about that story and then at
the bottom is where it can get a little
bit more self-promotional because they
want to say you know you are an expert
from whatever company the more you can
make it a story the easier it is for
reporters to be able to write about you
and if you make their job easier
they're more likely to do it if you
think about your experience between
advertising and getting featured in a
news story I take the news stor hands
down every time if you think about your
own experience reading a magazine for
example you spend more time reading the
ad you spend more time reading the
editorial all of the stories right which
one costs less obviously getting in the
media can be really cheap compared to
taking out advertising so it takes a
little bit of time to do it you got to
really think about your stories but I
found that to be super helpful and
helping me be able to get into a lot of
different media one of the tools they
also recommend on my tools that that
helped me is a service called PR leads
and should be somewhere here a lot of
different tools that used to grow my
business right here so it's under the
grow your business section a service
called PR leads and this is where
reporters will actually submit their
stories that they're working on and
they're looking for experts now there is
a cost of this is a $99 a month and I've
used it to get into New York Times and
fork and some other leading publications
and that looks really good you can put
that on your website that now you've
been a featured expert for whatever
publication and once that starts
everybody else starts coming so if you
get into one publication you'd start
getting calls from others and others and
others and it starts the snowball until
you become you know the expert the guru
for whatever industry that you're you're
in so I found off I needed to be highly
effective as well and helping me drive
business to my website and me not having
to spend a lot of money or zero on
advertising
thank you for joining me for another
edition of apps Gavin I hope you enjoyed
the video and I encourage you to
continue using SEO social media and
offline media to grow your business let
me know if you have any questions if you
liked the video and love to hear your
thoughts and feedback please give it a
thumbs up below and also leave a comment
as well and stay tuned for the next
episode